the paradox in this is and we rightly
fault the Bush administration for
imagining that somehow they could smash
regimes in Afghanistan or Iraq and then
the these places would we build
themselves organically we would say
happy to have helped and now we know you
guys want to do this on your own on the
one side on the other side there is a
neo-colonial problem and so they're both
is the need to recognize this is a
long-term slow process and you've got to
be there and it costs money and it's a
commitments beyond the term of an
individual president at the same time
you have to recognize this is no longer
the United States and the philippines in
1908 countries do not like to be seen as
submitting even to the most benevolent
colonial master so we have to find a way
of asserting a positive role without
triggering the nationalist impulse which
says I don't care whether you're good
for us or not I don't want to have you